the reason why I focus on the disaster
capitalism class and raise this
possibility that people might be
motivated by their economic
self-interest in these areas is because
it's one way of explaining this
phenomenon of there are calls are
slouching towards the apocalypse I guess
this is what I see when I read the
newspaper this that the most pressing
crises collective crises of our time and
we what we really need to address and
now as a species climate change Middle
East peace there's there is an amazing
less a fair attitude about these
disasters coming from our political
leadership
no the Annapolis conference is going on
right now and before it even started
there was this consensus that nothing
would come of this of this charade that
is this peace summit and next week is
the Bali Bali climate change summit and
pretty much everybody knows that nothing
is going to come of the Bali climate
change summit that you know before it
even begins
the most significant measure which would
be clear caps on emissions you know it's
pretty much off the table because of the
US Canada and some of the biggest
emitters so how do we and then on the on
the other on the other hand so you have
this less a fair attitude or this casual
attitude in the face of catastrophe from
our leadership and but then you have
this hyper activity around lesser what I
would argue or lesser threats
immigration you you have greater
activity around the terrorist threat
even though you have less you know that
you they've been fewer terrorist attacks
and certainly in North America and
Europe so you know how do we how do we
reconcile these trends this this
inactivity in the face of of major
disasters and an inactivity that
guarantees more disasters so I mean this
is I think this this is the trend that
we need to focus on the trend that we
need to focus on is why it is that when
it is so clear when there is a
scientific consensus that we are
contributing to climate change that this
is creating more and more frequent and
intense natural disasters that it is
creating mass and will create even more
mass migration of displaced people that
we are casual in the face of this
disaster then we also see a huge amount
of investment going on to the building
of fortresses the fortress economy so we
don't see the investment in green energy
we don't see the investment in policy
that will really address the biggest
crisis of our time which is climate
change and what we see huge investment
is it in the building of a fortress
continents weather Europe or North
America the major new investments in
high-tech surveillance virtual borders
the fortress fortress in ourselves in
and I actually think that what we're
seeing is one way of responding to
climate change and resource scarcity
this is you know there's basically two
ways that you can respond you can try to
get off this disastrous course through
changes in the way we live through
aggressive policy through real
investments in alternative energy um or
you can say okay this is inevitable and
there's going to be more and more
disasters more natural disasters more
Wars over scarce resources or terrorists
blow back from those resource wars and
what you invest in instead is protecting
the elites whether it's the elite
country
or the elites within those elite
countries and I think it's very clear if
you once again follow the money that
there is more for instance much more
venture capitalist money going into
homeland security than into green energy
that the market is banking on an
apocalyptic future and sees a profit
from protecting the elites from the
worst of climate change the worst of war
the worst of terrorism this is a new
economy this fortress economy and you
know we have to get off this course
because what we're actually seeing is a
kind of an endgame it's it's before us
now I don't think we can deny that we
that we see it this sort of world if I
call it the Green Zone and red zone
world and it's one of the things that it
you know I think a lot of people who've
been to Iraq you know have care we carry
with us is this image of the Green Zone
and the world divided between green
zones and red zones and you know I
always had this feeling when I was in
Baghdad that I was seeing the future if
we're not careful I've just the armored
neighborhoods the blast walls everywhere
the private security guards with their
guns pointing outwards protecting the
principle and everyone else can go to
hell I mean this is the world that's
created in these Wild West zones where
these policy makers get their way the
people who you know don't get everything
they want at home well they got
everything they wanted in Iraq and look
what they create it so we have these
this ability now to look into the future
look to Iraq I mean this is this is the
endgame and we have to make really
really hard choices that to get off this
course but just trusting the market to
do it for us or trusting you know this
political model to do it for us you know
what we're seeing what it's doing
you